[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs chaque jeudi
l'essentiel des informations pour passer
un bon week-end dans les yvelines et
tout de suite le sommaire de cette
semaine pour ces vacances de la
toussaint de nombreux sites yvelinois
passe aux couleurs de l'automne
citrouille animations et déambulations
sont au programme près de cinquante
artistes solidaires pour sa 17e édition
le marché d'art contemporain montigny le
bretonneux fait le plein une nouvelle
édition au profit de la recherche sur
alzheimer et aux personnes en situation
de handicap et l'agenda complet de vos
sorties au programme du cinéma du
théâtre et des expositions
on s'est parlé de vacances de la
toussaint les sites passe aux couleurs
de l'automne les sites russes sont de
sortie les animations vont de pair les
fermes de gally à saint cyr l'école vont
vous faire frissonner le château de
dampierre voyage et un carrosse en
citrouille en ces vacances de toussaint
le château de dampierre est passé à l'
orange
des couleurs chaudes pour le début de la
saison froide c'est toujours un moment
un peu triste la brume le matin la pluie
et autres et donc il faut donner un peu
de lumière dans cette pendant ses
vacances il ya quelques taches orange
qui sont opposés à droite à gauche sur
le domaine pour mettre en valeur tout
cela mais c'est surtout sur l'eau tom
l'automne avec ses feuillages avec ses
marrons et châtaignes et si l'on fait le
tour de tout le domaine on peut revenir
avec un panier de châtaignes on peut
revenir avec des marron d'inde
une visite qui se prolonge à la tombée
de la nuit citrouilles les décorations
s'illumine jusqu'au 3 novembre
[Musique]
à saint cyr l'école les citrouilles sont
aussi à la fête à la fois effrayante ou
amusantes
elles sont creusés par les plus jeunes
des ateliers sont proposés dès l'âge de
5 ans la fête des citrouilles est un
grand classique des fermes de gally
après avoir cultivé 10000 citrouille
dans nos champs dans la plaine de
versailles on les a récolté ces
dernières semaines l'atelier en lui-même
dur grosso modo une demi heure mais
durant ces journées on a les après midi
des représentations de théâtre autour de
bien sûr de la citrouille de manière à
pouvoir faire en sorte que les familles
puissent passer un après midi
sympathique le 30 octobre la ferme
ouvrira pour la première fois en
nocturne une enquête où les équipes vont
chercher à vous faire frissonner
[Musique]
les clayes-sous-bois vous invite à city
trouille pour vivre une journée autour
d'halloween des spectacles des ateliers
maquillage du minigolf et à 20h30 une
soirée dansante familiale conclura cette
journée c'est une soirée déguisée à
l'espace philippe noiret et halloween
toujours mais à voisins le bretonneux
cette fois c'est une après-midi et une
soirée cinéma qui vous sont proposées la
salle de la tour se transforment en
lieux de terra pour vous projeter trois
longs métrages
la soirée se terminera avec la famille
addams de barry sonnenfeld mais avant
vous pourrez découvrir ou redécouvrir
sos fantômes et à 16 heures c'est le
troisième volet d' hôtel transylvania
qui vous attend les organes en extrait
quelques mots suffisent à un homme pour
briller aux yeux d'une femme par son
intelligence adouli blague ou lydia sion
mines est assurée chérie tu avais raison
grand père valentim les monstres sont
écoeurants il ne se doute pas de ce qui
va leur arriver
après avoir présenté les contes de
perrault les playmobil sont de retour au
château de breteuil les petites
figurines allemande investissent
l'orangerie du site
cette année c'est l'histoire de france
qui est à l'honneur les visiteurs vont
pouvoir découvrir plusieurs saynètes sur
les 170 m² de l'espace durant deux jours
les 26 et 27 octobre
ils sont la collection personnelle d'un
grand collectionneur qui s'appelle
dominique béthune et qui collectionne
tous ces petits personnages depuis plus
de onze ans et il en a un nombre assez
impressionnant et il faut constituer
toute sorte de deux scènes de thèmes
pour parler des grands des grandes
époques de notre histoire je peux vous
dire qu'il y aura jeanne d'arc et la
révolution française
mais y en aura beaucoup d'autres plus de
50 artistes réunis à la ferme du manet
ce week-end c'est la dix septième
édition d'armes année avec non plateau
le président du lions club les trois
villages à coutures rouges
bonjour alors qui dit marché
international de l'art contemporain ce
que ça veut dire qu'ils viennent de très
loin ses artistes
alors effectivement donc on a
premièrement des artistes qui sont
locaux dont qui viennent 30% à peu près
des effectifs viennent donc de la région
et cette année on a trois trois artistes
qui viennent donc de decosse de la ville
jumelle de guyancourt et donc ça va nous
faire un petit côté international donc à
notre manifestation alors sur ces
artistes qui viennent certains c'est la
première fois c'est un tiers d'entre eux
comment vous vous rapprochez de ces
artistes
chose étrange mais depuis 17 ans donc
les artistes dont que ça fonctionne
beaucoup par le bouche à oreille c'est à
dire que les artistes parlent de la
manifestation donc nous avons toujours
un site qui est alimentée avec les
différentes manières et des différentes
oeuvres est donc mal les artistes nous
appellent et puis prennent rendez-vous
et confirme d'ailleurs très tôt dans la
saison donc pour être sûrs de participer
en 17 éditions vous avez fidéliser
les artistes le public aussi alors le
public également nous avons des
aficionados donc qui nous qui nous
suivent est et tout en essayant
d'améliorer la qualité des oeuvres et en
essayant de diversifier également
passant par la sculpture la peinture en
passant donc par la photographie qui est
très très demandé ces derniers temps et
donc voilà ça se fait le fil en aiguille
et c'est très plaisant de ne pas enfin
de pouvoir avoir la qualité est de
pouvoir offrir aux habitants de la
région donc une qualité donc dans ses
oeuvres
c'est ça il ya différents styles aussi
on ne doutait pas d'un seul à on va dire
non on essaye de n'ouvrir on essaye de
on veut apporter de la curiosité qu'on
veut et puis également créer un échange
avec donc les artistes et et que le
public puisse poser des questions
puissent se renseigner et donc on l'est
puis on les accueille aussi on apporte
notre petit une touche d'amitié aussi
qui est très importante dans cette
manifestation est l'une des
caractéristiques de votre événement
c'est l'aspect caritatif voilà les
bénéfices faute à qui alors ça change
d'année en année mais basiquement ça va
donc pour la maline la maladie
d'alzheimer ou alors donc la
maltraitance ou alors le handicap
alors l'année dernière nous avions donc
fait un don pour la maladie alzheimer et
cette année nous allons récompenser
enfin proposer ou oppressé et de
collaborer à un projet pour la
maltraitance et est donc mais voilà tous
les ans on essaye de trouver quelque
chose en fonction des projets qui nous
sont proposés qui nous sommes sollicités
de toutes parts et donc je vais vous
faire un choix il faut faire un choix
mais donc nous faisons en toute
connaissance de cause et on fait
toujours un choix pour que le don qui
est effectué et des répercussions
locales
elle est donc
du public et des achats puisque l'entrée
du site est gratuite alors l'entrée est
gratuite et grâce à un partenariat avec
la ville de montigny
donc nous nous arrivons donc à alors
nous l'ont les stands donc aux artistes
et puis après nous rémunérons aussi un
petit peu avec les boissons les cafés et
puis également donc la tombola
tous les ans nous organisons une tombola
le lion achètes une oeuvre est donc là
mais hélas propose au public
nous aurons également trois prix le prix
du public le prix du lion's-club le plu
de la ville
merci jacques audio pour mieux découvrir
tous ces artistes ils sont presque 50 il
faut venir le tout a laissé il a vu du
beau de nous voir venez nous voir vous
ne serez pas déçus on peut pas le mieux
le dire on rappelle juste les dates
c'est les 26 et 27 octobre ça se passe à
la fin du manet de montigné votre ne
ouverture des portes à 10 heures un
petit mot de cinéma à présent si vous
vous laissiez tenter par une séance de
cinéma en ces vacances de la toussaint
plusieurs longs métrages sont sortis en
salles mais quel ennemi d'euros et
patrick jacques de dixmude sont allés
recueillir les avis de plusieurs saint
quentinois
écoutez cette association répond au
besoin de manger
alex était patient que la société
refoule ou qui semblent impossibles à
améliorer
[Applaudissements]
je recommande vraiment on va aller voir
ce film c'est vraiment un super film est
à tout point de vue vraiment très très
émouvant tous les cas c'est tout chaud
c'est éprouvant et en même temps on
s'est mis ces merveilleuses qu'il faut
vraiment très juste
avec un jeu d'acteur fantastique et puis
non une certaine réalité qui est qui qui
nous laisse un genou laisse pantois
qu'ils arrivent à les sortir un petit
peu quand même du néant
salut petit ou petites
oui disent confiantes tu es bien un
garçon je sais pas d'où tu viens
il s'échappe et je veux récupérer ma
yéti j'ai adoré c'était trop cool j'ai
bien aimé film parce qu il est il a bien
été réalisée c'est très bien et il faut
protéger les animaux c'est pour les
enfants c'est un bon moment il ya des
musiques sympa ces jolis seins c'est une
histoire qui se laisse regarder
c'est plutôt familiale tout le monde
peut y aller les petits les grands les
moyens pour tout le monde
[Musique]
découvrir le territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines à travers les lignes de bus
et les pistes cyclables
l'artiste mexicaine sandra hernandez
s'est prêté au jeu proposé par la
commanderie un mois d'immersion sur
l'agglomération qui a donné naissance à
une exposition flâneuse présente 17
détroit nikisch est pris par la
photographe regarder le principe c'est
trois semaines de résidence
une semaine où on fait la production de
l'exposition et une semaine ouvrent la
présente on a choisi des photographies
qui se répondent de plastic man c'est à
dire que les lignes et les couleurs se
répondent pour que ça forme un ensemble
cohérent et harmonieux
ce week-end il ya aussi du sport
notamment du basket trappe jouera ce
week-end dans le championnat de
nationale 3 les trappistes vont recevoir
saint thomas basket le havre pour le
compte de la 5e journée du championnat
un gros match en perspective
les deux clubs sont dans le top 6 et la
rencontre est programmée ce samedi 26
octobre à 20h à rambouillet la lanterne
accueille ce samedi le troisième trophée
dans ses spectacles un rendez vous
organisé par l'association danse et vous
78 à partir de 11 heures vous pourrez
assister aux éliminatoires la finale se
tient elle à partir de 20 heures
on fait maintenant un petit tour en ile
de france
[Musique]
jusqu'à quel point peut-on pousser
l'amitié pour le savoir il faut aller
voir la comédie donnant donnant au
théâtre de paris sur scène deux couples
se retrouvent pour une soirée qui doit
changer leur avenir chat car chacun a
une faveur à demander à l'autre un sujet
de nos confrères de via grand paris
c'est quand même temps meilleurs pas
demain non et christophe aussi moi je
parle plus facilement mais christophe et
puis christophe et une bouche donc on
[Musique]
enfin le jour christophe il trouvera du
travail travail l'instituteur
éventuellement ils peuvent apprendre à
lire donnant donnant c'est une histoire
de compromis dans cette pièce
rocambolesque deux couples se retrouvent
pour un dîner qui va très vite se
pimente et romain est aux abois
financièrement car sa carrière de
comédien ne décolle pas et il va
demander une faveur à son ami bastien à
qui tout réussi professionnellement
oui mais voilà bastien a lui aussi
besoin d'un service
lulu et romains veulent demander du
boulot à bastien qui est un businessman
qui réussit qu'à beaucoup d'argent qui a
une boîte de pub et en ce qu'on ne sait
pas c'est qu'en fait
bastien et isabelle eux veulent du
sperme
voilà c'est exactement ça que les gens
tous les soirs mon mari va siens il
malheureusement stérile aller les
couilles vide dit et donc voilà donc
comme je veux absolument un enfant on
vient demander du sperme
je suis là on n'a jamais donné de ce
père a été déféré première fois qu'on en
demande
avec ce grand dilemme qui se pose pour
romain et lucie la comédie pousse le
spectateur à se demander ce qu'il ferait
dans la même situation et fait écho à
l'actualité sur des thèmes comme la pma
par exemple donnant donnant une pièce où
chacun peut se retrouver
c'est vrai que pour ça on est assez
oui ça peut concerner tout le monde
d'abord jusqu'où on va en amitié
jusqu'où on est prêt à aller
ce qu'on peut demander d'ailleurs je
pense que les gens se posent des
questions qu'est ce que moi je ferai à
la place de romain
qu'est ce que je ferai ce que je dirai
oui ce que je dirai pas ce que c'est
quand même une
on donne son sperme donc forcément il y
aura des conséquences sur l'avenir
et oui d'une comédie mais qu'il ferait
réfléchir un peu donnant-donnant est à
voir dans la salle régional du théâtre
de paris jusqu'au 5 janvier
c'est la fin de cette ut loisirs merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve jeudi
prochain
[Musique]
m
pour